my name is Aaron McCormick chief
executive officer PT conf inside here at
the economic summit in New Delhi I think
it's fair to say that India is going to
be a global superpower I think that our
definition of what constitutes a super
car is out of it I believe that soft
amar and economic power and influence
are becoming much more important than
the hard military definitions of our
super car is I believe that India's
levels of innovation and the sheer size
of the country and the fact of the
scarcity is driving levels of animation
that are not seen in other parts of the
world pretty much predestined India to
become one of the major superpowers of
the 21st century of the new Israel